363 شخصا تركوا احبائهم وضحوا بارواحهم
مقابل حمايه اشجارهم
قبيله بشنوي في الهند واحده من اشهر
القبائل حول العالم حبا واحتراما لكافه
اشكال الحياه على الارض
في ولايه راجستان شمال غربي الهند اكبر
ولايات البلاد مساحه يقطن مجتمع كامل يعيش
في تناغم واتساق مع الطبيعه قد تبدو هذه
الاشجار مجرد نباتات عاديه لكنها بالنسبه
لمجتمع البشنوي ليست كذلك فالدماء بذلت
والارواح ازهقت لحمايتها القصه تعود الى
عام
1730 للميلاد احد الملوك المحليين ارسل
جهده لقطع اشجار هذه المنطقه لبناء قصر له
تصدى الس كان للجنود وهرعت امراه تدعى
امريكا ديفي لمنع الجنود من تنفيذ مهمتهم
لكن رجال الملك قطعوا الاشجار وقطعوا رؤوس
امريكا وزوجها وبناتها الثلاث وبعد انضمام
السكان للدفاع عن الاشجار وصل عدد القتلى
الى
363 شخصا خلدوا في ثقافه
عبر مئات السنين
[موسيقى]
مجتمع البشنوي الزراعي والبالغ عدده نحو
مليون و500 الف نسمه يؤمن ب 29 قاعده
حياتيه ودينيه
جميعهم نباتيون لا ياكلون اللحوم ولا
يدخنون ولا يشربون الخمور ويؤمنون بان
زراعه الاشجار وليها من صميم معتقديم
الديني
احدى القواعد 29 تامر المؤمنين بعقيده
البشنوي بعدم زراعه او استهلاك الافيون
لكن العديد منهم يخالفون هذه القاعده
يعني
[موسيقى]
مجتمع يعتمد على زراعه كل ما يحتاجه
والنساء هنا عليهن العبء الاكبر في توفير
الغذاء لاسرهن
بادريغاروتازيما
[موسيقى]
قلبي اهتماما كبيرا بالحيوانات ايضا على
غرار اهتمامهم بالنباتات والاشجار فهنا
مراكز لانقاذ الحيوانات الضاله او المصابه
يقدمون لها العلاج والرعايه بمجهودات
وتبرعات اهل القبيله وبلا اي دعم حكومي